since we have been given our first look
adobe one kenobi series in the form of a
poster a lightsaber can be seen in
obi-wan's right hand us fans have
noticed that this lightsaber actually
seems to be anakin skywalkers and not
obi-wan kenobi's it's not confirmed that
the lightsaber is anakin's but due to
the shape of the hilt it appears to be
the blade that obi-wan will eventually
pass down to luke if we zoom in here and
have a closer inspection and compare the
hilt of obi-wan and anakin we can
clearly see this is without a doubt
anakin skywalker's lightsaber like it
looks nothing like obi-wan kenobi's
lightsaber um there's a clear
distinction between the two of them um
they're very unique looking hilts and i
believe this is actually anakin
skywalker's lightsaber now anakin's
lightsaber is a symbol that any star
wars fan can recognize immediately in a
new hope obi-wan brings luke back to his
heart on tatooine and briefly tells him
about his father the clone wars and the
jedi order then he grabs the box and
pulls out the lightsaber that belonged
to luke's father anakin skywalker gives
the weapon to him when referring to the
time period prior to the reign of the
empire obi-wan says before the dark
times those dark times that he is
referring to on a fall of the jedi
during order 66 it is safe to assume
that obi-wan didn't just lock anakin's
lightsaber way after he took it from him
in revenge of the sith having spent many
years with anakin as his apprentice and
the two fighting side by side all
throughout the clone wars the old jedi
master probably feels an enormous amount
of guilt about his apprentices fall to
the dark side uh mcgregor recently
confirmed that he and hayden christensen
were able to film scenes together
suggesting that there will most likely
be flashbacks before his transition into
darth vader meditation is a common
practice for jedi in it and it is likely
that the series will feature at least
one if not more scenes of obi-wan
meditating over anakin's lightsaber the
lightsaber definitely holds a lot of
pain for the character and while it will
often remind him of what he has lost it
can also be used to relive some of the
best memories he ever made now i feel
like we'll definitely see obi-wan
communicate with qui-gon jinn in this
series because at the end of revenge of
the seth yoda goes on to tell kenobi as
training for him and that qui-gon jinn
has learned apart from immortality and
how to commune with him yoda will teach
kenobi what do you guys think do you
think obi-wan is holding anakin
skywalker's lightsaber let me know in
the comment section below and if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe thanks for watching guys